finding the ending of a movie is  extremely hard especially Toy Story film  where you wanted to be really impactful  and really emotional this one came  pretty close in this ending bow saw this  child that she connected with and she  realized oh I actually would like to be  with the kid again and would he realize  in that moment I'm gonna have to like  bow go so it's much more bitter Sweeting  from their relationship woody  everyone is with a kid I can't believe  you actually did it we did it though  together thank you  [Music]  she's the one what the girl from the  store she's the one  I feel a connection again woody like I'm  supposed to be her toy  Molly  Andy Bonnie all these kids we're there  for them we belong to them but I want  you to know I'm yours  I always will be  and I'm Yours Sheriff  goodbye Bo  [Music]  you  [Music]  [Music]